[Music]
come on guys it's time
we're gonna be late to the Royal Wedding
let's go get married what I mean let's
get Bridget and Crystal married yeah
yeah wow
it's a crazy bachelor party uh Cloud guy
don't feel so good
tiny diamond you make the cutest Little
Flower Boy come on Daddy I'm the cutest
Little Flower Man
do you leave I love it we are gathered
here today
I'm John Dory branches long lost brother
[Music]
you're the guy from bro Zone we were
just listening to them
but that's all in the past
you got a secret brother correction used
to be my brother
my brothers walked out on me and never
came back Branch we're out of sync we've
gone from Boys to Men and now there's
only one direction for us to go the back
streets Bridge it's time to find the
rest of our brothers and get the band
back together bro we're gonna have the
best family reunion ever Frozone 2.0
Frozone reunion Frozone Here We Grow
Again Frozone where's they bro I don't
know we're gonna find them
[Music]
random dude on another Musical Adventure
oh hey tiny you see that button right
there oh you mean the button is taking
every fiber about being not depressed
press it
[Music]
wow too much hustle is a thing
huh look at that
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign